[Musica]
non è na na na na na na na na na na na
na na na na na na na na na na
che canzone per fare un tavolo ci vuole
legno per fare legno ci vuole l'albero
nessuno ha detto è per forza funziona
così ho deciso di stravolgere il mio
terre di ieri mentre era in volo appunto
da new york così
e mentre in volo pensavo ai miei amici
alla mia rete le persone con cui scambio
costantemente fiducia un valore
conoscenza e mentre pensavo a tutti i
miei amici ho pensato a mia madre al suo
sguardo
il primo rapporto umano è stato con mia
madre il primo rapporto di fiducia e
stato come madre in quello sguardo nei
primi sei mesi ognuno di noi ogni
bambino ha una ricca interazione con la
madre di sguardi di dialogo con la ricca
interazione lo porterà a creare i
modelli relazionali che lo
accompagneranno per tutta la vita
fiducia fiducia fiducia tra madre e
figlio tra figlio e comunità tra figlio
e il mondo
umberto galimberti scrive se pretendo di
imparare a nuotare
prima di entrare nel mare non imparerà
mai a nuotare
ho scoperto un esempio fantastico di
fiducia grazie alla comunità degli
italiani di frontiera e parlo di amedeo
giannini banchiere del 1900 fondatore di
benko vitali che poi diventa da bank of
america italiano di origine amedeo
giannini nel 1906 riaprì per primo la
banca tutti i banchieri a san francisco
dopo il terribile terremoto al 1906
vogliono riaprire dopo mesi e mesi a
novembre vi disse non possiamo aspettare
novembre novembre avremo una città
deserta bisogna aprire ora scesa in
strada riuscì a recuperare un sacco di 2
milioni di monete d'oro dal suo capo
dice su un banchetto di legno ecc ad
erogare prestiti a tutti tutti anche
quelli senza garanzia per lui la fiducia
a guardare un uomo negli occhi
oggi la scuola ci si propone spesso
percorsi rigidi percorsi lunghi percorsi
che ci invecchiano percorsi che aria
metà percorso dovremo cambiare
siamo siamo ingabbiati nel continuare
percorsi che ci rendono ubbidienti nel
1400 le nostre botteghe quelle degli
artisti dei pittori ospitavano talenti
che ogni giorno si concentrano a fare
qualcosa di nuovo ogni giorno
sperimentavano qualcosa ap una nuova
conoscenza e si sporgevano oltre sempre
cose nuove sempre cose che non avevano
mai fatto prima
gli veniva data fiducia per fare una
cosa che non avevano mai fatta prima e
andavano avanti grazie a questa fiducia
grazie a questo rischio
probabilmente dobbiamo tornare ad essere
agili come in quelle botteghe tornare ad
essere oggi ad innamorarci modo ha già
ad orientarci in modo agile ad imparare
in modo agile fiducia il rischio sono
due modi rivoluzionari per approcciare
alle soluzioni approcciare i problemi
direbbero in tecnologia è qualcosa di
distrarli e la fiducia a qualcosa di
destructive è qualcosa di necessario
rischio che conviene correre david
clementoni ne ha insegnato una frase che
salta e vedrai apparire la rete la mia
fortuna è oggi che ogni volta che sono
saltato
mi sono trovato una rete una rete di
persone che mi dava fiducia ad andare
avanti a sporgersi di più a rischiare
quando avevo 12 anni sviluppato siti web
e pensavo di sviluppare siti web per
tutta la vita impari a fare qualcosa
dici wow so fare qualcosa posso mettere
a disposizione la farò per tutta la vita
poi un giorno arriva mio fratello dice
jacopo c'è un software complicatissima
di montaggio e tu sei uno smartphone e
vedi se lo riesce ad usare non riuscivo
ad usarlo era davvero troppo complicato
però conosco dei maestri di montaggio
non potevo permettermi nelle loro
lezioni diventiamo amici scambiamo
conoscenza scambiamo consigli di contino
e il penso di voler fare il montatore
per tutta la vita
in ciò ad appassionarmi alle riprese
ovviamente penso di fare le riprese per
tutta la vita ogni volta che scopro
qualcosa grazie alla cosa precedente
penso di farlo per sempre mi appassiona
al marketing penso di fare il consulente
di marketing per tutte
capisco che bisogna avere una visione a
360 gradi delle cose e pensi di fare il
dj life coach per tutta la vita
quando ho creato il gela scoccio detto
questo penso di farlo per tutta la vita
ma sono consapevole che mi porta da
qualche parte che vi porterà lastre da
altre parti
sarà per forza si e non vedo l'ora di
conoscere dove mi porterà il digitale
scotch
spesso mi chiedo quale sarà il rapporto
tra uomo e macchina
penso che le macchine vada data la
storia tutto quello che abbiamo scoperto
la nostra conoscenza le nostre
statistiche e dobbiamo tener per noi il
buon senso le emozioni la capacità di
rischiare la fiducia così possiamo dare
origine a nuove cose sempre nuove cose o
si gira alle macchine alla storia
all'uomo il futuro prendiamoci tre
secondi per pensare cosa ci spinge ad
incontrare nuove persone
grazie
[Applauso]